foreign
foreign
foreign
the three Muslims today we are missing
brother fayad he just couldn't make it
today so may Allah bless him and uh yeah
other than that we got the main base
here alhamdulillah how are you doing
angel
because
I'm doing good how are you guys doing
all right someone someone said we should
put a recitation in instead of a boring
countdown
I think that actually is a Brilliance
that's pretty smart we just gotta factor
in the whole uh copyright stuff yeah
maybe I'll ask yahia for permission to
use one of his recitations
that he could get all because Mr Youssef
recommended it
bless you
llama I mean
people are already um
arriving to certain conclusions remember
what happened in Malcolm X as soon as he
converted uh to to True Islam he got
people already kind of jump into that uh
that conclusion there
all right so um I guess without further
Ado let's um talk about the elephant in
the room the thing that people
are here for the thing that everyone is
talking about currently
hopefully I can pull up the Right video
because there was a good video I got and
a bad video of God so let me hopefully
pull up a better one
foreign
[Music]
appreciate it
[Music]
so yeah last night Andrew and Tristan
Tate were both arrested in Romania it's
a it's a long story I don't know how
much of it we should actually talk about
how much of it is important to talk
about but um on Hill how surprised were
you when you got the news
I wasn't surprised man when you sent me
the message
same here a part of me like was shocked
and the part of me wasn't shocked I was
more so shocked that he was in Romania
um and uh I was also a little shocked
that it was out of anyone who would
arrest him it was the Romanian police
but
to each of their own there's a lot of
different things going on surrounding
the reason he was arrested was it this
reason was that reason
um I'm not going to say any terms that
would get our our video
um
I'm just going to say de-leveled but um
yeah I think you guys know
um yeah so yeah
did you catch when they were showing him
inside of the actual like vehicle here's
like this
yeah yeah I I wouldn't be surprised if
they didn't like were looking at it like
this is just this is just the show
whatever you know let me just
you know get some no no I'm sure for
them it wasn't like as big of a deal as
like a lot of people are making it out
to be yeah like if you actually looked
at it like there are people who are
really overreacting to it and the people
that are overreacting to it are the ones
who uh have been hating on him yeah yeah
100 you know my my friend asked a very
interesting question on Tick Tock he's
like to all the people that really don't
like Andrew Tate do you want him to be
guilty or do you want him to be innocent
and it's a really good question because
if someone hates him so much that
they're like I want him to be guilty
then that's like saying I actually hope
he did these crimes I actually hope he
did XYZ horrible things to these people
just so he can be thrown in jail and I
can hate him uh or do you want him to be
innocent meaning that he never did these
crimes uh in the first place I think
those are really interesting questions
if anyone really wants him to be thrown
in jail I think it's important that you
ask yourself that question as well
yeah
um we have one Super Chat the first one
of the day may Allah bless you yo says I
know this is extremely random and off
topic but could I hit you guys up uh for
off stream I'm a Reaver for about seven
months my mom passed away this morning
before I was able to give her a proper
dawa may Allah bless you and um and and
forgive us Allah I mean uh of course bro
just hit my hit my idea either the three
Muslims on Instagram or me personally
and I will definitely get back to you
I'm sorry so much for your loss may
Allah make it easy for you and uh please
DM me uh if you need anything
Insha'Allah sure enough
it's crazy man yeah I love Mercy on us
man
all right I mean
um
so
there are a few comments that stood out
to me uh firstly
uh our brother here says if you must
love you guys keep up the great work may
Allah bless you guys and all of us along
man I mean
um this one stood out to me tonic says
guys The Matrix like you think they talk
about isn't real of course people are in
power but it's not like some crazy stuff
like in the movies
yeah no this is what kind of made me
laugh when like he's he's actually being
detained and then he literally said like
the Matrix has attacked me like you got
to give it to an immense consistent bro
yeah and that's consistent yeah 100 and
I think
I think um using terms like the Matrix
is it could be beneficial and it could
be not very beneficial because a lot of
people can understand the term like the
Matrix you know and they kind of know
what he's talked about when he says it
but at the same time it opens the doors
for people like this to
um and I'm not saying people like him
like it's a bad thing but like people
who just don't believe it exists to kind
of make it more of a fairy tale to be
like they're already using like a fairy
tale kind of word a movie word Matrix
they made a movie about it it must only
happen in movies for people to run with
that narrative is a little bit easier
but there's an actual uh political term
called The Deep state which like you
have the state then you have the deeper
level of the state which I guess instead
of being lower it's actually higher
because it's higher up on the um
hierarchy and it's the people who are on
top the people who are really deciding
what gets pushed and I just want you
guys to think about this
um America has never had a a time in its
life or the West has never had a time in
his life where it didn't have a face of
liberalism a face of you know democracy
a face for the West the face at one
point was fighting you know Germany in
the 1940s
um and and you know people putting
people in their black book and so on and
so forth and fighting for their freedom
and so on and so forth and uh before
that it was them finding a great enemy
that actually was the Muslims in World
War one and then after World War II you
had the fight against you know crime and
drugs and then after that you had the
fight against the t word which were
basically Muslims in the Middle East
they went and they fought and bombed and
attacked our places in the name of
liberalism and freedom and now if you
think about it what is the face of their
agenda the alphabet gang
that is the face of their liberalism and
so on so forth and that is what they're
pushing nowadays so even if you don't
believe in a matrix
you have to understand like you said
there are people on Power and power
people on top pushing a very specific
agenda and I think that's something that
most people can concede to but what do
you think on health
so the brother said that it's not
something that's like what's in the
movies
and that's true
to an extent
and what I mean by to an extent is that
like
uh I would
classify the Dunya asymmetries but it's
not the Matrix like in the movie
it's just the Dunya is basically the
Matrix that we live in the the
simulation that we live in but it has
nothing to do with the actual movie it's
completely different yeah
100 yeah
and that's the question I would actually
like to ask Andrew Tate we should uh we
should write that down
write it down for if insha Allah
inshallah we have a good to talk to him
inshallah
all right let me remove some of these uh
and jump to the next one
just to put it straight As Muslims we
don't need anyone to be by our side
because we have Allah we also shouldn't
believe the nose without anything uh
with anything they say it's but to be
honest especially without any proof of
accusations 100 yeah and this actually
leads me to another topic that is
related I want to discuss which is how
should Muslims react when there is kind
of a Muslim in in uh in the news and
it's being claimed that they did XYZ
um as Muslims we are obligated obligated
to review the evidence
and see what was actually done
based on the evidence before we come to
any conclusion verdict or slander or
backbite or whatever
and I would I pray to Allah that if some
false news ever comes out about me or on
Hell or fired or one of our very close
brothers that Muslims will give them the
benefit of the doubt until there's
evidence for whatever is being claimed
about them there is a very clear example
of how the media loves to just use very
very extreme titles and I mentioned the
guardian using 6 500 migrant workers
were as a result of the World Cup in
Qatar but that number was highly
misleading because it wasn't 6500 based
on building the structure it was
literally every migrant worker who by
the way two-thirds of the population are
migrant workers who passed in Qatar for
any reason since the announcement of the
World Cup being held there which was
told like 12 years ago so you see how
they love to like throw things in there
and they're rarely ever held to account
when they basically lie so let's be
careful inshallah and also any profanity
will be blocked immediately no time out
for you bad people you get blocked
completely
um
I like that I like what you said man
because
we got to remember that the news the
media they always have an agenda
they always have a specific thing that
they're trying to get through like a
narrative that they're trying to push
through
and if if they are trying to push this
through
and this narrative that they're trying
to push through is a result of people
that are actually higher up than them
that are you know maybe giving them the
money or the paycheck whatever it is
right it's
this is like hierarchy that's going on
like you you kind of mentioned
and we have to take everything
like at face value and then we have to
like you said evaluate the evidence
because if we just accept something like
they say blindly
oh
bro you you're an NPC at that point
you're a sheep you know and like
I think as Muslims that's one thing that
we shouldn't be we shouldn't be sheep
we shouldn't be NPCs
100 and on top of that
Allah will hold you accountable
every word you say I think about it like
there are people who really don't like
ensure like they hate him imagine
getting bad Deeds because he spoke bad
about him because he's a Muslim now you
know what what in your eyes what bigger
L could you could you take so let's be
fair not for Andrew Tate not for me not
for on Hill for the sake of Allah and
actually for the benefit of your own
self because if and you do any wrong the
Allah is going to be the one hold you
accountable I'm not gonna you know
appoint anything to your throat and make
you apologize Allah will hold you
accountable and Allah says if you're in
punishment so that's something we should
all be
conscious of inshallah
marawan says the most funny thing is
that they created human rights and after
they imposed their laws to other
countries uh don't even but don't even
respect them by doing worse things like
in Libya Syria Iraq
very very true very true
um it just reminds me of what you
remember that that funny interview with
the uh Ugandan
interviewer yeah yeah yeah the it was a
human rights activist yeah
yeah and it's just I was just throwing
in there because the whole human rights
thing is it's kind of funny if you dig
deeper into it yeah 100 because I mean
they made the criteria
and then they enforce the criteria on
other people they are currently even in
Qatar to this day condemning Nations
based on the criteria and then they
themselves have been breaking that same
criteria for the last decade
and and it's it's funny because people
will will reject the idea of a deep
state of a matrix of people on top with
with certain agendas that are being
pushed and so on and so forth because we
have you know certain practices like
freedom of speech and things they like
to say
they don't actually really exist
especially nowadays uh when you have
things like for example after World War
One America put in this law saying that
you can basically you cannot make the
military look bad you can't have any
propaganda against the military you
can't lie about the military you
actually can't even say truthful things
about the military if it looks if it
makes them look bad and you can't reveal
any you know military documents that are
classified or whatever footage that's
classified
um you know or else you'll see you'll
serve up to like 174 years in prison
right which is like two lifetimes right
so this is this is insane and the reason
this is insane is because recently there
was a guy who founded an organization
called Wikileaks and they recently
leaked a very specific video from
um the military
the US Military and I think it was Iraq
but I'm not sure you guys can verify
that and there was a bunch of people
there's one guy holding a camera
literally a camera over his shoulder
there were kids there was somebody on
the phone they're just walking and the
soldiers they were in you know when you
play Mario and you're yeah you're in the
AC-130 right you know the view from the
AC-130 you see like the gray it's a
black and white image you see the
crosshairs that was their view they were
literally in like a gunship or some kind
of um drone or something
and the soldiers were asking do we have
permission to engage do we have
permission to engage and one guy
literally was like come on man let us
shoot let us shoot like he's begging to
shoot these innocent people and they got
permission and they did it
long story short Wikileaks got hold of
that video they leaked it to the world
what does America do
what does America do do they a apologize
for what happened
do they be
punish the the militants and the the
commander at the time
see
say that they're going to take
precautions to make sure this does not
happen again and reimburse the families
and help them in any way or see or sorry
or D
say it's not our fault and actually
blame the person who released the tape
for releasing the tape
news flash it was D not only do they not
admit fault or help the innocent people
who whose family were you know offed or
like even even admit it was a slip at
the slightest they said it's not our
fault at all and now they're going to
put the man in jail for up to 174 years
what's even crazier is this man's not
even a U.S citizen he's not a Canadian
citizen he's an Australian citizen
residing in the UK so America wants him
so bad they've been pushing to get him
uh extradited from the UK to America
just so they can throw him in prison
yo
I know don't talk about this stuff I was
about to say but you trying to put a
price on my head I'm in the U.S right
now man come on why just just yell at me
and say you're wrong we fight for
liberalism we fight for democracy what
are you talking about well technically
we we don't know 100 what we're speaking
of so
is that what they're speaking of unless
they are using the most basic of of
facts
bro when we speak about Islam I know 100
what we're speaking of
pardon me when we speak about Islam we
know 100 what we're speaking of
um not always
yeah we know 100 of what is reviewed
that's what we speak of we don't speak
of anything else other than what is
revealed yeah but there's interpretation
involved in stuff
of course well
[Music]
um
side note Discord server inshallah I
think we will be starting up a Discord
server very soon I think it's long
overdue and I personally never saw the
value in it until recently so I think it
will be good in Charlotte for the
community
um encouraging says it's insane how the
World Cup had little to no coverage in
the mainstream media in the west yeah
there are people who didn't even show
the opening ceremony like they didn't
want to see Morgan Freeman up there or
something like I don't know what's wrong
with these people
um
foreign
I don't know
I don't know what that is Rami means
like thrower or Archer which is why I
want to go
um
uh to an archery range
but I haven't yet inshallah I'll keep
you guys closer and if I'm actually good
or not if I live up to the name
um another thing is so what impact do
you think
um Andrew Tay being a Muslim has on the
whole like uh attack against him or or
dislike of him
I think it's it's something that these
people who
if there are people if there are people
we'll say like that
you know if there are people that are
higher up and they are like
orchestrating this whole thing and um
first they try to cancel him
and then now they try to falsely
imprison him
she made a video where he said that when
you play this game
you have three lives and the first one
is uh you get canceled and the second
one is you get policy in prison and if
the first or the second one don't work
then the third one is you pretty much
get off
right so it's like if if we're talking
about that then uh technically he's he's
going on to his last life in this game
uh so may Allah protect him and never go
out but getting back on topic
how does uh him being Muslim affect this
whole thing bro they can use that
heavily heavily to try to throw uh Islam
under the bus as they've been trying to
do
this entire time they've been trying to
make Islam look at like it's a religion
of uh tea you know what I'm saying
you know they try to make this this
religion to be something that's like uh
violent and um something that's pretty
much
it's just not what it is it's a very
peaceful religion when you actually look
into it it's very just very fair
religion
it's it's exactly what it should be it's
it's the truth you know but they're
gonna use it bro if they get any if they
get any sort of like
hit on him or something like this bro
they're just going to use it as like ah
look he became Muslim and Muslims are
this isn't this and it's like bro the
sheep that are listening to this uh
material they just they already think
badly about Islam now they're going to
think even worse about is that
yeah 100 and
it's it's funny because in regards to
the whole like Matrix deep State
conversation
um I think like those people and their
Specialists and whatever know more about
Islam than the common person
especially Islamic history and what
holds Muslims and Islam together because
if you just read history and see what
happened after World War one which again
their enemies were the Muslims
they split up
the Middle East into all these different
nations to keep them divided based on
nationalism
why did they do that why
they did that because we are commanded
by Allah
hold on to the Rope of Allah altogether
and do not become divided because what
happens when you're divided you lose
your strength you lose your power that's
why you have a billion Muslims
two billion Muslim normal around the
whole world
which is what a quarter of the
population
and we have no strength No Authority or
anything that's because they split us up
and made us disunited
so they understand Islam very very
intricately and they've been working
since they broke Islam apart
up until this point to make sure it does
not remain a power which is why they
went and attacked a lot of the countries
in the Middle East how many stable
countries are there politically and
economically in the Middle East that
have not basically fully uh adopted this
Western liberal Democratic way of life
or they're not willing you know to go
against what the West says
there aren't any
is that a coincidence
oh
we got a two talking about America bro I
it's not a coincidence man but he never
got a chill talking about America bro
like next thing you know I'm gonna go
missing
why would they take you bro I don't know
man I'm just I'm playing around I'm
playing around but seriously like when
we when we talk about things like this
we should definitely should definitely
be good to
um like off public type thing whether it
be like a Discord or whether it be like
on a website or something like this
because I mean bro there's so much that
we can say but then again like on
YouTube on YouTube though like come on
come on bro okay inshallah very soon
we're gonna revamp our website so any uh
any topics or content We cannot put on
YouTube for
um you know Community purposes we will
put on our website inshallah so if any
of you guys are web developers and then
have spare time and want to uh help us
revamp the website sha Allah we welcome
you on board and if not then I'll
probably try and do it myself but it
might not come out too nice
like people are saying Rumble Rumble
Rumble would be actually the the easier
way
it's an option
yeah
um should you go to high school if
there's so if there's much Haram
um interesting question
where do you live
that's uh another like context question
that I would like to ask that's a good
question in in Haram like in what sense
what is Haram is it because there are
sisters there is it what they're
teaching you
all that stuff is important
and um I think at a certain age you can
some places you can basically do High
School courses and credits online you
get a diploma online which is really
that difficult to just take your math in
science and in English and then
you know you'll be going inshallah in
America you can do this
it's called um at least in the the state
that I used to live in in Florida they
call it uh FLVS Florida Virtual School
Florida I think Florida learning virtual
school or something like this but yeah
like uh I think I took the whole ninth
grade on uh online wow it must have been
chill man no it sucks actually because
you know it's you as like when you're
younger you want to be like you want to
go to school to be around friends
yeah that's true so when you're home
alone is it like a ninth grader
so it gets a little a little sad bro
there's only so much Call of Duty and
RuneScape that you can play at that
point
yeah that's very true bro enough Call of
Duty you'll just end up going mad those
lobbies are pretty toxic man yeah
um did I go to a Christian School yeah I
went to a Catholic School
um for all four years
um this person said uh Andrew literally
or where's the thing
Andrew literally sniffed on himself it
was a bit funny the way they caught him
do you know how they caught him
how dedication so he made a video on um
post on Twitter to that that Greta
thunderberg person and in the video he
brought out like pizza boxes and they
they saw what the logo was and then they
called The Pizza Store and asked where
it was delivered and that's how they got
his address and they pulled up
apparently apparently I haven't heard
anything like solid about that or since
anything's solid but that's what
um almost everyone is saying about it
damn yeah
but it doesn't matter how smart we are
whether it's like books motor Street
Smart like
at some point you're gonna you're gonna
miss something
and you're gonna get got someone wrong
yeah but nothing will strike us except
you know uh
of course of course of course
yeah yeah of course they already know he
was in Romania of course but um
why would why wouldn't they just arrest
and look on the spot
that's what I was curious about like how
did he get in without even being
wrestling on the spot
they probably got the location from
some kind of source
because I highly doubt that he would
just
have like a specific place that he goes
to and like the government and
everything just knows okay this is his
location and all that like if he's
talking about the Matrix and all this
stuff and if the Matrix is really after
him like why would you have something
that's like well known like all this is
what a state can get me
you know like so I'm pretty sure there
had to have been some kind of source
that gave out his whereabouts yeah
um somebody asked a um
actually I think a very good question
I couldn't find it I keep losing these
uh sorry I can't put your comment up
because I can't find it but somebody
asked what do we think of
uh the tweets that he was making in
regards to Greta and like all that stuff
have you seen it
so
I don't know I feel like
Andrew Tate is a lot more like a lot of
what he says is more
like exacerbated and and polarizing and
a little
I don't even know the word little root
to be honest in some regards
um whereas when you listen to him speak
in person on podcasts with people it for
me it doesn't give that that same kind
of vibe
um I first want to say that I I don't
think it's worth it really engaging in
in such a manner with with people
especially a 19 year old
um I just don't see the benefit in that
if if he wanted to attack the movement
or something she said in particular I
think that would be
um that would be a lot better if there
was something a reason to attack the
movement a reason to attack what she
said if she said something then I'm
speaking from ignorance I don't know
what she's done and what she said I
think that would be better but to kind
of engage in the petty discussion this
is on her part as well to go back and
forth in this pettiness I think it's
really cringy to be honest I think we
should just have civil normal
conversations
um
and yeah go on
no I think it's
I think it's a carefully calculated
you know I think this is all done where
it's like it's truly done for Sharp
value
and um they'll have sharp value but then
like
if you really look at his content the
podcast and like when he speaks on my
normal things normal videos and stuff
like this
the shock content shark value is like
maybe 20 to 40 and then the rest of it
is like actual practical advice or just
like normal conversation normal like
real life stuff right
so it's like the man is smart he knows
what he's doing when it comes to
marketing though
so it's like uh we could look at it and
be like oh I know like you shouldn't do
this you shouldn't do that and it's like
yeah yeah this is true
but you can't you can't deny that he
knows what he's doing
yeah 100 I'm not saying that he's he's I
mean he's the most popular person
probably in on the internet right now
I'm not saying from a like pragmatic
standpoint from a publicity standpoint
but I'm just saying mainly from an
Islamic perspective
um it's not befitting of a Muslim to
engage in these kind of things to use
that kind of language to say and the
only reason like I I haven't really said
anything about it publicly is because
he's a new revert
um but at the same time like it gets to
a point where it's like yeah you have to
advise a brother so for him and
everybody else you know there are
mannerisms that a Muslim needs to have
that the process had when he engaged
with people even Allah and he tells us
to basically speak words of Peace even
to like people to even to like Angry
ignorant people to speak words of Peace
Allah tells us to basically effectively
and efficiently and politely debate with
people and argue and discuss but not in
like an argumentative fashion but in a
logical and rational way
um and also with good characters that
the best of you are those with the best
of character and I think that this is
something that can only help The Message
of Islam and um and by extension the
message that Andrew Tate wants to to
promote Insha'Allah so long as it is in
line with what Islam is teaching
I wonder if anyone's actually told him
but he lives in the UAE and he's
probably around a lot of people who do
practice he probably has contacts with
uh multiple sheikhs yeah I mean he was
even in contact with the father
um I just I wonder man like if anyone's
actually said anything to him
no
I'm not like I know I know what you said
he's very new as well he's a river so
these things are to be taken into
consideration
but at the same time too like
I wonder if he's like reached he's
received this he's received this like
nasiha this advice
but it's not him who's actually putting
certain stuff up so it's someone else
that's like
in control of like the the whole
marketing stuff and like what's being
put out there in the little clips and
stuff like this and he's just kind of
like letting it go and maybe he's just
not aware of it right now
but I don't know I can't even sing too
well yeah thank you Allah
um Allah knows best at the end of the
day it's it's it's it's for the Muslims
who have the ability you know the
prophet son of me said when you see an
injustice or anything that's wrong uh to
stop it with your hands and if you can't
stop it with your mouth and if you can't
then at the very least you hate it in
your heart you know you don't like that
thing in your heart that's all we can
really do inshallah
um I I'm I'm wondering why does everyone
hate Greta so much I'm not saying you
should or shouldn't I don't know
anything about her other than her being
like a
um climate change activist and all that
stuff which I do want to talk a little
bit about because I I definitely don't
know a lot about it but I do think there
is a point to be made because I've heard
I think actually Andrew Tay himself said
it in a video uh Candace Owen said it on
Joe Rogan's podcast and I think there's
this really weird narrative going around
that climate change is a lie or a myth
and I think that there are two extremes
possible in this case
and I would like to hear what you guys
say about inshallah but everyone's kind
of just like insulting her
um
you know she's a woke mob freak
she's a climate change girl okay but
like can I can I get a reason
explanation not just name calling and
stuff I don't think that's beneficial
but
there's um I think perhaps there's two
sides to like two extremes to the
situation I think there are people that
saying climate change is not real which
I think is is crazy to say to be
completely honest
um
um because it's something that is is
testable it's something that's
foreseeable it's something that is is um
uh measurable you can measure the rate
in which the climate is changing what we
are doing to the ozone layer what we are
doing to the Earth and we could see that
like yeah it's getting hotter faster at
a faster rate this whole thing about
weather changes all the time that can
always Candice owes was saying on
jorgens podcast I think is very very
fallacious because it's the straw man
and Joe Rogan I'm sorry I don't
completely dislike your organ but when
you make Joe Rogan seem like like
like a brilliant person like brilliant I
think you're on the wrong side of the
the battlefield to be completely honest
um because he was explaining to her how
climate change works and and he broke it
down and called out her fallacy and
strong men and it's very true climate
change definitely worked or it
definitely is is is a problem but I
think there's another extreme which is
let me use this problem to benefit as
much as possible there maybe there are
people who want to pass bills to tax you
know middle class and and the average
person more to fight climate change
instead of just
fighting it themselves going at the
corporations that's causing this Mass
pollution and all of these issues
um that's the extent of my knowledge on
this what do you guys think
this person says coffee lover says
Romney should know that you should know
climate change
you should know climate change hoax is
exaggerated by the left to get votes and
scare people so is it a hoax is it
completely made up or is it something
that's true that's exaggerated which one
is it I think it is true and maybe it is
exaggerated but but that doesn't mean
it's not an issue and I I don't think
actually I don't think exaggerated is
the right word to use I don't I think
that's wrong exaggerate is definitely
not the right word to use because what
are they exaggerating the issue
no because the issue is a big problem
what they're what they might be doing is
using that problem that does exist that
is an issue that we need to fix to
benefit themselves maybe they have plans
so that they can make more money so
whatever it is
it wouldn't be completely impossible in
this capitalistic world that we live in
sorry Arnold do you have any thoughts on
this
yeah I was going to say we should look
at it through the lens of a Muslim right
and we got to understand that everything
in this world is uh it's meant as a sign
and this in and of itself like whether
it's it's a
as bad as they make it out to be or not
uh like you said it's you can be you can
see it's Freedom like it's happening
like something is clearly happening and
it's a sign in and of itself you know
because I was watching this one video
where
these are these people who are not
Muslim they're talking about how water
came to the Earth and they said that
when the earth first started supposed to
be like this it was just like a rock
like it had no water supposedly and that
water came from the um like asteroids or
whatever it is like this the comets and
if you actually look into it like the
Columbus asteroids are primarily
composed of water and then it's like
when you look in the Quran Allah is like
literally telling us like that he
brought down
water he brought down the water to the
Earth to the Dunya and
um he can also take it away
and it's like just I don't just looking
at that just listening to that and then
kind of reflecting on this it makes me
think like okay well this is cool with
your son you know and we should look at
it as a because it's it's a sign letting
us know that this is all temporary it's
all going to be taken away very very
soon and um instead of trying to uh get
to the point of what it always is it
really real is it not real is it um as
bad as it making it out to be easy not
as bad as they make it out to be I think
we should just take it as that as a sign
reflect on it and just come closer to
Allah
inshallah inshallah
our uh brother here I think his brother
says can you be sure of a sincerity of
his conversion history is full of fakes
he may fabricate agendas or may use
Muslims to protect himself from the
Matrix I like him but not trust him from
the moment well we can never really know
if someone is sincere or not
um and as um who said he narrated that
when the Quran was being revealed and
the prophet son was alive we would use
the Quran as a way to you know basically
judge people right but after the
Revelation stopped we would go based on
their actions what we can see from them
what I have seen from him personally
recently has mainly only been good
things
obviously he's a human I think he's had
slips here and there but I think for the
most part he seems to be very sincere
you might have a different opinion about
the end of the day it's not for us to to
judge or take action on that part you
can judge and have an opinion be wary no
worries but there's no action we could
really take and we can't say he's not
sincere that's something you cannot say
um so we have to be careful a history
full of fakes okay maybe he may
fabricate agendas again maybe I don't
think Muslims have much power to protect
them against any any agenda or whatever
I think Islam has a solution
but for him to use a solution he'd have
to be a sincere Muslim I think he is
inshaallah
and as Muslims we should avoid suspicion
of our brothers and sisters in Islam
like whether you sincere or not that's
that's Allah that knows and we if I
might never know that's very true like
it's it's like asking oh is Romney since
you am I sincere like how would y'all
know
because we have YouTube videos that talk
about Islam because we've been Muslim
for x amount of years like
how would that be the uh the factor that
indicates our sincerity like only Allah
knows like we there's no way we can
actually know yeah yeah that's very true
that's very true one one Hadith that
kept coming up is the Hadith where
um there is one sahabi who was at the
battlefield fighting in a war
and they were chasing after this one man
to basically strike him down because he
was fighting against them and the man
before he was struck down he said the
shahada he said
he said that he accepted Islam right
before he was about to be you know offed
and the sahabi offed him anyways and the
prophet sallam when he heard about this
he he asked the sahabi he's like he's
like basically why did you do it why
would you you know do that to someone
who just accepted shahada he said he was
just doing it the time he said he was
just doing it so he can live that's it
he wasn't being sincere the prophetam he
said did you open up his heart and see
what was inside of it
this is someone who was literally five
seconds ago just fighting against the
Muslims
five seconds ago and Prophet sallam
asked did you open his heart and see
what was inside of it I think that
speaks volumes inshallah
Angela
um there's another Ayah actually in
Surah Arun Allah
he says corruption has appeared
throughout the land and sea by what the
hands of people have earned
may Allah may let them taste part of the
consequence for what they have done so
perhaps they will return
you know territiousness to piety to
goodness
and if you see what this huge
capitalistic system has produced and you
know how we have become so
industrialized it's produced
all these greenhouse gases which by the
way basically majority of it is is
produced by corporations and these
factories and all all these um
you know production facilities
and it's breaking the ozone layer and it
is you know corrupting damaging the
Earth you know all the Plastics that we
put in the sea and all that stuff is is
done by human beings and we're seeing
the result of of our actions here as
human beings so Allah has put us as a
Khalifa on this Earth Allah said he
announced the Angels I'm putting on the
earth a Khalifa
Khalifa meaning what a successor someone
to take charge a ruler the leader
human beings are like the leader of the
Earth
which means you have yes rights and so
on and so forth but you have huge
responsibilities
huge responsibilities
and when you have the wrong people in
power
you have corruption and talhoot and
tyranny upon the whole Earth
to give a further example about the
whole like sincerity aspect
um I won't say any names because I don't
want to expose anyone's sins here but I
know this brother
who is supposedly
hey
he's a scholar
and he's very trusted he like was looked
up by many people
went to him from much much advice and uh
guidance on certain things not guidance
because it's from a lot but Clarity on
certain things
and then come to find out that this uh
[ __ ]
was stealing money from the Masjid from
the donations
you know and like
how would anyone have known because in
in it in everyone's eyes this man was
sincere this man's a scholar he studied
Islam how could he not be sincere so
again
only Allah knows what's within someone's
heart I we will never know what's in
someone's heart soul isn't it takes and
[ __ ]
hold on Knows Best
and it's not even beneficial really to
to question things like this
um in this manner
so I'm just going through some of the
comments right now
I wanted to uh progress and move on to
different topics but it feels like
everyone is uh staying on this topic
understandably
um there's this one thing that I've seen
a few times I love Robin but I'm
disappointed in this climate change
propaganda
um just listen I'm I'm open to any
evidence give me the evidence show me
why it's fake and false and propaganda
what parts of it are wrong I'm willing
to learn I've said well I I know so far
or at least what I I believe and think I
know so far if anyone disagrees please
um just give me the evidence for it
thank you
Muslims might must follow the straight
path 100.
100 percent
this is a funny question
where did you get your plant in the
background
fayad got it from I think like a thrift
store or something like that
it's not real
this this office is fully enclosed it
would die very very soon unfortunately
um
does no one care that Elon Musk is
pushing propaganda that Islam stands
with the rainbow agenda
um I've not seen that
I've not seen that someone else
commented saying that he put like the
Islamic like half moon and Crescent
thing with the like rainbow flag
a lot of people don't understand it's
not I think Elon Musk is another person
is very very ignorant of Islam and what
it actually has to offer because you
guys have to understand Islam has been
reduced nowadays Sam has been reduced to
uh something that is just in the heart
something that is just in the home
something that is just in the Masjid but
that's not what's time is the slam
encompasses literally everything in life
every aspect of human Affairs Islam has
some kind of position stance or ruling
on it
so
um to say that it's something that's
just in you know the heart or just in
the house is completely false um they
think it's Progressive they think all
these ludicrous things but they don't
actually understand what Islam is so I
would like to talk to people like Elon
Musk to educate them on Islam and tell
them what you know what it's about and
how it can actually help them in their
lives and many of the Nations that are
struggling
I wonder how you actually talk to
someone
this man is like
foreign
would just be somewhere else
you know like
smash trying to go to Mars bro he's
trying to develop like some kind of like
uh
Community some place where people can
actually live in Mars
I don't know maybe you just tweet at him
or something he owns Twitter no no no
I'm saying like in person like how would
I just don't understand like how you
would get through to Someone Like This
um
I know a lot of people have this weird
this weird thought that since they see
somebody online a lot that they know
them and they go and try and talk to
them in person like they know them and
this guy's like I don't know who the
heck you are and it's like it's an
awkward moment but I think it would have
to come from the people close to him
um or obviously from somebody who he he
trusts
yeah yeah so the best thing we can do I
think is just make videos and speaking
about it and mention him by name and and
politely just educate him on Islam
Lay It Up
is it haram to smoke weed so first and
foremost go ask a scholar this is one of
the more basic ones so generally yes
it's Haram to smoke weed
um there actually perhaps can be
exceptions like medically speaking um
but that is you have to go to a Sheikh
about that and to a doctor about that
and get the ruling from him but
generally it taught him to smoke weed
laughs
you shouldn't make a show out of Islam
that is what happened with some Muslims
and Andrew Tate and that is what
happened with how people were watching
the Morocco Moroccan football time
um what do you mean with make a show out
of Islam I'm curious what that means and
I think a lot of people actually they've
really fell in love with the
um you know Islamic etiquettes of the
Moroccan team where they would go into
sujud after you know in celebration that
would go on prostration to Allah they
would go celebrate with their mothers
you know these are things that have
Islamic uh bases to them and roots to
them so I think people really actually
appreciated that
yeah it's like uh
when he would win the fights he would go
into prostration yeah
yeah 100 and that's why a lot of people
ended up coming to Islam because of of
characters like heavy
so to say like don't Islam shouldn't be
made a show like I get where you're
coming from but
okay
you can tell that to someone who
influenced
thousands if not
maybe millions of people we don't know
yeah yeah and generally
this is this is very general but like
generally when you criticize someone you
have to ask yourself what are you doing
you know what I mean like
and this is not about me but this is
about anyone like if you're going to
criticize people like the Moroccan team
or someone like um you know like
Mohammed hijab or anyone who gives dawah
you have to ask yourself what are you
doing for the sake of the dawah you're
sitting behind a computer and it's very
easy to criticize from the point of
being behind a computer and commenting
especially with an anonymous profile but
to put yourself out there for the sake
of Allah and work and be you know from
the the stabby [ __ ]
from the forerunners you know that's not
something that is easy that's why Allah
rewards these people so much because
they're doing the work of you know that
the prophets were doing so let's be
careful inshallah when we criticize
people one amongst the things that I
think we should learn is good character
and that's something I hope inshallah to
learn myself and to teach you guys
um good etiquette good character from an
Islamic perspective
yeah
it's easy to
you know criticize
someone else but to criticize ourselves
that's hard
yeah very true there is a Hadith I don't
know if it was from the prophet saws
himself
um someone please let me know but there
was a Hadith that mentioned
um that said hold yourself accountable
before you take into account
very very powerful
very powerful
may Allah make us sincere
I mean Europe I'm in Europe
people are going people asking crazy
things you know
what what are they asking doriani or
Mandy that's what the conversation has
gotten to now
come on bro
Mendy
I was about to say the same thing Monday
is just
oh my God it's amazing man
it really is yeah it's amazing and now
not like bro my mom and my wife know the
recipe so when they make it like I don't
have to drive all the way to Mississauga
an hour and a half to get it and pay 100
bucks for it my mom and my wife make it
I'm still thinking about that uh coconut
cake that your mom made
a wild bearing oh my God
you had like half half the cake no bro I
think I had the entire thing she made it
twice yeah
yeah that's funny man but you made those
uh plantain things right yeah yeah
that was good that was good yeah yeah
um our brother here
um again just like last stream is Miss
belt on Hill
uh they said Rami has been there you do
have a beautiful view man it's
um bro like I remember when you were
trying to grow it out and you're like oh
bro like it's not growing in it's not
growing in and mashallah look at it now
bro alhamdulillah
you know you just gotta put in that work
with the Derma roller with beard oil
monoxide are you actually doing that I
was doing that yeah
I I actually I shouldn't have stopped
because it's still like very
you know what's the words
but if you would have started up like I
mean it wouldn't hurt you know
yeah yeah
um I think I missed some super chats
there's this one yeah we had um we had
one of the the subscribers they reached
out to me on Instagram saying that we
ignored the chat but we definitely
didn't know it's just sometimes we we
just miss them no no I I saw I got the
same messages because of what he said in
the Super Chat it was um
[Music]
yeah uh but brother Raymond said sadly I
saw this live very late God bless my
brothers Insha'Allah 2023 bring even
more blessings
I mean thank you for tuning inshallah
you can always rewind the tape and go
back
um
uh don't know if this is the real size
of the Femme I'm going to assume it's
not but um Sajid lithium because he
donated pounds I don't think he's in uh
the UK or anywhere but if Andrew takes
yeah if Andrew Tate gets killed uh oh I
mean offed
um I'm convinced The Matrix a matrix
exists if that's what it takes for you
to understand then I think maybe you
need to readjust your criteria because I
think there are many other evidences
that um
bro
there's so many people that like the
moment they spoke out but they just got
taken up yeah yeah
um is hak says
what is your advice for finding a
partner
um
first thing I would say is get closer to
Allah
and um you know start getting more on
Dean as well
and then from there you praise the
harder
and you ask Allah to put the appropriate
person in your life
and it just kind of happens from there
you know like we do our part and Allah
takes care of the rest
yeah 100 you gotta you know you got to
take action you gotta Network you got to
talk to your married friends ask if
their wives they ask them to ask the Raj
if they have any friends and so on and
so forth but it will happen when Allah
Wills that's I think that's how it is
for everyone they're looking they're
looking and if they finally find someone
and they're like wow you know this came
out of nowhere it's only gonna happen
when I lost my thought of bills
um people are calling me out rightfully
so because I don't have my currencies
right trying to find the comment here
um
is in U.S so it would be USD not pound
or Euro yeah 100 100
um
um I uh true boxing King says
just wanted to drop in I'm also
been Muslim for almost 28 years
alhamdulillah
dude I'm 29 man
Allah
uh dang
when you were one he accepted Islam
[Music]
yeah
bless you bro
I mean yo Donuts says you think the West
would ever allow a Muslim country that
follows Sharia fully absolutely not uh
the night and day between societies
would be crazy listen there is literally
no way on the face of the Earth
that they would be okay with that
I mean look at the
and this is me like speaking about
Muslim countries without saying anything
uh that this is actually a good thing if
you think about it but um in in Muslim
countries
um even though supposedly Sharia is not
uh adhered to a hundred percent
they have a lot of aspects of sharia so
like for instance if if someone steals
and there's evidence there's four
Witnesses then you're getting your hand
chopped off especially if it's over x
amount and you're over a certain age and
stuff like this and everything lines up
perfectly it's like
bro I told that to my mom she was
disgusting she's like how could that how
could you guys do something like this
I'm like are you serious say let me ask
you something if you if there was a
possibility of your hand getting chopped
off would you ever steal anything and
she's like no that's that's barbaric I
was like exactly
that's just how it is in America man
it's it's a soft soft face yeah and and
if you think about it I was actually
reflecting on this recently not only is
it a huge deterrent but it will
basically stop you from ever stealing
again how are you gonna steal with one
hand
yeah how are you gonna do that bro
you're gonna like grab one handful bro
and people will look at you and see like
oh damn like he stole look what happened
to him and they're like no no I don't
want that yeah yeah but also there's a
possibility of someone just losing their
hand in war or naturally and then you
know that sucks yeah but how are you
gonna Rob people are you gonna be like
you're gonna be like
put the money in the back
yeah no for real for real for real
um but it's like if you would have
compared to what they do in uh Western
prisons it's like okay someone someone
robs they just put him in jail for x
amount of time and they get out of jail
and it's basically what like this little
slap on the wrist and they go back and
do the same thing yeah yeah 100 and also
they're less deterred from doing it
because worst case scenario they go to
jail for a few years and sit in prison
cell so some people that actually
doesn't bother them at all that's why
there's a lot of second time offenders
third time offenders so on and so forth
yeah to them they see it as like oh um I
got caught how can I better do it to not
get caught
that's very true very true uh Victory
says may Allah bless His Channel with
Baraka I mean Allah
uh stupa says always great to see you
guys uh and not been to Friday Masjid
yet I'm kind of anxious about going as I
don't know much Arabic hopefully I get
there next week inshallah may Allah
bless you make it easy for you you don't
need to know Arabic to go trust me
you're gonna walk in maybe say is great
people you're going to sit down you're
going to listen to a lecture you're
gonna get up and you're gonna be led in
a prayer so you just have to follow
along inshallah don't worry
yeah you'll see that your mind was uh
making it out to be
a bigger deal than it actually was
absolutely absolutely I think inshallah
we're um we're gonna come to a close
very soon we'll take a few more comments
and questions uh and then we will wrap
it up
I do think a Discord for us would be
prime yeah yeah 100
yeah absolutely if we create streams
like
on Discord but it's like proper proper
like private streams or we can
technically we can say whatever we want
on these streams
like that's real bro
that's that's the realest podcast this
is like the realest edited podcast in
the Dunya the the realist what is it um
it's not filtered but um
reduced no no what's the word when you
uh
restricted
yeah this is like the realest restricted
podcast in the Dunya
that was funny man you could stream on
Rumble yeah yeah
um streams I don't know I think for the
bigger topics the tougher ones will
probably just pre-record and put them
like on our website or something
uh
um is it true if a married woman refuses
to please her man she will be punished
well first and foremost there is no
worldly punishment
um that exists
um and again the Hadith what it says is
if basically a man wants to be intimate
with his wife and his wife and for
contacts this is without any reason she
doesn't have any physical ailments she's
not you know too physically tired she's
not mentally like drained or out of it
or something like that it would not harm
her in any way but obviously for an
alternative reason she says no Then the
angels will curse her and if you think
about it it's long story short there's a
huge discussion on Tick Tock like a year
ago about this if you think about it
Intimacy in that way means a lot more to
a man than it does to a woman for a
woman it's important for both men need
it more frequently and um they're a
little more driven by that so A woman
and there are women by the way look it
up it's called sex manipulation we'll
use it to manipulate their husbands oh
he didn't you didn't take all the trash
well you're not getting any tonight it's
Petty and it's toxic and it's not
something that is um congruent with a
stable household or relationship
it's also applies to the Man Too if the
woman is requesting to have intimacy
with the man and the man rejects for no
apparent reason
then he's also cursed am I correct on
that I I don't know I I haven't heard
the the kind of flip interpretation but
it's definitely wrong for a man to
wrongfully to do the same thing is
obviously wrong for him as well
um
uh and he's denying her one of her
rights which is is not something he
should do
man I wanted to put that comment up but
don't think it would be good
I can't I don't think I should talk I
should read it
Anonymous says the Muslims knew about
masculinity and men can be women we have
past great Muslims as a role models but
we needed someone like Andrew Tay to as
links to the CIA from his father to
speak up well I don't know what the
links to see anything
um I haven't heard of that either
um something about your name being an
honest makes me not want to trust that
information but
um yeah you know Allah he causes certain
people to
to you know benefit the community and
sometimes people spread Islam while
trying to do the exact opposite without
knowing so Allah will do as he was
alhamdulillah and the last superchar
inshallah we're going to take MDX Joseph
says move tremble
y
that's another thing again as we
mentioned earlier we were discussing
maybe putting some content uh on there
yeah and what this brother said I think
there's a very smart
because if you think about it like yes
we have the best role models to look
back but we're human man like sometimes
we need something like right now that we
can physically see and perceive and
Allah always provides that for us
whether that be our father whether that
be a brother that we just met a scholar
or maybe just some random influencer or
something like this
yeah 100 absolutely
and um I think the the long and the
short of it is when the truth comes to
you no matter how it gets to you or
where it comes from when it's the truth
and it's clear it's the truth you need
to accept it whether it's a young person
advising an older person or a dumb
person advising a smart person or
whatever you know you might see as a
lesser person advising whatever you see
as a greater person than when the truth
comes you have to accept it Allah says
in the Quran the truth has come and
false falsehood falsehood has vanished
indeed falsehood is bound to vanish
because when you are given the truth you
can no longer actually believe anything
that is false because you've been given
the evidence your mind will not
logically want to conceive that and if
you try to force it you'll have
cognitive dissonance and end up very
very upset
yeah and at that point if you rejected
it's just arrogance
yeah
absolutely absolutely but I think
inshallah with that being said we're
going to close off the stream until you
have any final thoughts
all right without being said
for everyone who tuned in may Allah
bless you all immensely remember to like
subscribe share the stream and uh don't
believe anything until you're given
evidence
and with that being said